Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
(Música)
Probablemente ya saben que todo está hecho
de unas cositas llamadas átomos.
Quizá sepan que el átomo está formado por partículas aún más pequeñas
llamadas protones, neutrones y electrones.
Y quizá han escuchado que los
átomos son pequeños.
Pero apuesto a que no han pensado nunca cuán pequeños son realmente.
Bueno, la respuesta es que son muy,
muy pequeños.
Entonces, ¿cuán pequeños son los átomos?
Para entenderlo, hagamos esta pregunta:
¿Cuántos átomos hay en un pomelo?
Bueno, supongamos que el pomelo está hecho sólo de átomos de nitrógeno,
cosa que no es así, pero hay átomos de
nitrógeno en el pomelo.
Bueno, para ayudar a visualizar esto, hagamos cada átomo
del tamaño de un arándano.
Entonces, ¿qué tamaño tendría el pomelo?
Tendría que tener el tamaño de la Tierra.
¡Es muy loco! Entonces, ¿si llenamos la
Tierra de arándanos,
tendría la misma cantidad de átomos de
nitrógeno que un pomelo?
¡Correcto! Entonces, ¿qué tamaño tiene el átomo?
Bueno, es muy, muy, muy, muy pequeño.
Y, ¿saben qué?
Es mucho más loco.
Ahora veamos dentro del átomo, es decir,
el arándano.
¿Qué ven allí?
En el centro del átomo está lo que llamamos núcleo,
que contiene protones y neutrones,
y por fuera vemos los electrones.
¿Qué tamaño tiene el núcleo?
Bueno, si los átomos son como arándanos en la Tierra, ¿de qué tamaño es el núcleo?
Quizá recuerdan las viejas imágenes del átomo de las clases de ciencias,
con este puntito en la página y una flecha que apunta al núcleo.
Bueno, esas imágenes no están dibujadas a escala;
por eso son un poco erróneas.
Entonces, ¿de qué tamaño es el núcleo?
Si abriéramos el arándano
en busca del núcleo,
¿saben qué? Sería invisible.
¡Es demasiado pequeño!
Bien. Expandamos el átomo, el arándano,
hasta el tamaño de una casa.
Imaginemos una pelota del alto
de una casa de dos plantas.
Busquemos el núcleo en el centro del átomo.
Y, ¿saben qué? Apenas podremos verlo.
Para poder entender cabalmente
el tamaño del núcleo
tenemos que expandir el arándano hasta el
tamaño de un estadio de fútbol.
Imaginemos una pelota del tamaño de un estadio de fútbol
y que nos sumergimos en el centro del átomo,
encontraríamos el núcleo, ¡podríamos verlo!
Tendría el tamaño de una canica pequeña.
Y hay más, si es que aún la cabeza
no les ha explotado.
Veamos un poco más del átomo. Tiene protones, neutrones y electrones.
Los protones y neutrones viven dentro del núcleo,
y contiene casi toda la masa del átomo.
Bien en el borde están los electrones.
Si el átomo fuera una pelota del tamaño de un estadio de fútbol
con el núcleo en el centro, con los electrones en el borde,
¿qué hay entre el núcleo y los electrones?
Sorprendentemente, la respuesta es:
espacio vacío.
(Ruido de viento)
Correcto. ¡Vacío!
Entre el núcleo y los electrones, hay vastas
regiones de espacio vacío.
Ahora, técnicamente, hay algunos campos electromagnéticos
pero en términos de materia, está vacío.
Recuerden que esta vasta región de espacio vacío
está dentro del arándano, que está
dentro de la Tierra,
que en verdad son los átomos del pomelo.
Bien, una cosa más. Si es que puede
hacerse más extraño.
Dado que prácticamente toda la masa del
átomo está en el núcleo...
hay algo de masa en los electrones,
pero la mayoría está en el núcleo,
¿qué densidad tiene el núcleo?
Bueno, la respuesta es loca.
La densidad de un núcleo típico
es de 4 por 10 a la 17 kilogramos por metro cúbico.
Pero es difícil de ver. Bueno, lo pondré en unidades inglesas:
2,5 por 10 a la 16
libras por pie cúbico.
Bien, sigue siendo difícil de imaginar.
Haré lo siguiente.
Hagamos una caja de 30 cm, por 30 cm, por 30 cm.
Ahora tomemos todos los núcleos contenidos
en dos autos típicos.
Los autos pesan en promedio 2 toneladas.
¿Cuántos núcleos de autos habría que
poner en la caja
para que nuestra caja de 30 cm de lado tenga la densidad el núcleo?
¿Un auto? ¿Dos? ¿Qué tal 100?
No, no y no.
La cantidad es mucho más grande.
Es 6 200 millones.
Es casi la cantidad de personas de la Tierra.
Si todos los habitantes de la Tierra tuviese su propio auto
y si...
los pusiéramos a todos en la caja,
ésta tendría la densidad de un núcleo.
Es decir, si metiéramos todos los autos del mundo en la caja de 30 cm de lado,
tendríamos la densidad de un núcleo.
Bien, repasemos.
El átomo es muy, muy, muy pequeño.
Pensemos los átomos de un pomelo
como arándanos en la Tierra.
El núcleo es extremadamente pequeño.
Ahora veamos el interior del arándano, expandámoslo al tamaño de un estadio de fútbol,
y ahora el núcleo es una canica en el centro.
El átomo se compone de vastas regiones de espacio vacío.
Eso es extraño.
El núcleo tiene una densidad muy alta.
Piensen en todos esos autos en una caja de 30 cm de lado.
Estoy cansado.
(Bostezo)